cbs news medical contributor that's dr
david agust joins us now to bring us up
to date on all the latest covet stuff i
want to pick it up david with where meg
just left off that they did not require
a negative test after five days of
isolation that start that struck a lot
of people's not making any sense did it
make sense to you
certainly if we had the resources in the
ability i think a negative test that
five days makes all the sense in the
world when you look at the data
it takes about seven days till most
people start to test negative and some
even longer so having that negative test
is a way to stop the virus the problem
is we are still limited with testing in
this country
but i also heard the cdc say that
sometimes you can test positive even
though you're no longer emitting any of
the you can't you you can test positive
although you're no longer dangerous and
that's why they said listen you don't
after five days you're okay
it was very confusing yeah i mean there
isn't
you're right there is an issue is that
the test looks for 30 letters the 30 000
letters of the code and you could see
that in viral fragments so you may test
positive even though you're not
infectious and we've seen people test
positive several weeks out without being
infected so it's not you know a simple
answer certainly if you test negative of
five days it is safe for you to go out
with a mask over the next five days the
real question or the others we need more
testing testing needs to increase across
the country to be able to stop the
spread of the virus
let's talk about the kids going back to
school because schools really seem to be
trying to figure this out do you think
it's safe for children to go back into
the class
today
i think we're going to have to you know
we have to have in-person learning and
what we need is again more testing in
the school so testing should be mandated
in schools and if you test negative you
can go to school i think that's the way
we should be doing things and much of
the world is doing that particularly in
the european countries and you have to
have a mass mandate when numbers are up
like they are in most of the country
with omicron
let's talk about the number of uh
omicron cases we keep hearing the the
numbers are very scary david you hear
300 000 that they've topped we keep
hearing it hasn't even hit the peak yet
should we be focusing on the number of
cases or the number of hospitalizations
how scared should we be about this
number
i think you hit it gail and we had a
half a million cases in a day over the
last few days and so hospitalizations
are what matter if you look at a state
like maryland that has one of the
highest vaccination rates they're at the
highest rate of hospitalization they've
been in throughout the almost two years
of the pandemic so there are places now
where particularly unvaccinated
individuals with this rapid spread of
omicron are basically filling up
hospitals we're canceling elective
procedures in much of los angeles i've
had patients cancer patients where their
surgeries for cancer have all been
cancelled over the last week and going
forward because hospitals are building
filled up and what we need to focus on
is that number because that is what's
limiting our society in many respects
and so omicron will spread we're going
to peak over the next several weeks
particularly in areas that had an early
onset of omicron and then it'll go down
afterwards but over the next several
weeks it's going to be rough
all right david egg as it all boils down
to once again you got to get your
vaccinations and your boosters thank you
dr akas i know we'll talk again